[Music]
[Music]
Sunday afternoon in the city of Chetumal
in southeastern Mexico a chance to spend
time with the family and let someone
else do the cooking on weekends there
are lots of tasty treats on offer here
are all in one take home runs a popular
stand his speciality tacos el Pasto
Shepherd style before it lands on the
grill the pork is marinated in pineapple
dried chilies and spices
it's served on tortillas or with bread
a generous squeeze of lime juice and
they're ready to go
some like a sprinkle of onions and
coriander too so delicious why flavor is
sensational the pineapple the lime it's
something special there's an array of
extra sauces and toppings and Raul has
other meats we serve paprika sausage
marinated pork and cutlets and for the
discerning palate bachata fine skirt
steak customers often order as many as
seven different kinds of tacos each one
costs 60 Euro cents the meat is really
good the sauce is a special blend of
spices not too hot the pork is nicely
browned hardly any other stand has such
a variety of sauces and veggie toppings
on offer it's so good even after
nightfall the customers keep coming top
seller is pork tacos al pastor it's
something you'll find everywhere you
find it all over Mexico everybody likes
it visitors tourists everyone and Raul
will serve many more before the day is
done